uh let's blow up the 2021 running back
draft rankings as compiled by
christopher david sims number one
clemson running back travis atn why is
he your top guy but he's the the most
complete running back most made for the
nfl
player running back in this draft and
has it all and really has like no
weakness to his game mike i mean really
reminds me of a player you know in a lot
of ways it's a he's a alvin kamara
kareem hunt type of player where there's
some true value in his ability to run
between the tackles you know he can run
with physicality he does a great job of
like like a chimera kind of like not
that he's gonna break your ankles and do
that type of stuff where the defender's
gonna fall over but has great balance
and stays low to the ground to where you
know gets on the edge of would-be
tacklers and spins off them or they just
get a piece of his thigh and he breaks a
tackle that way let alone when he sees a
little hole mike he can put the the
pedal on the metal and really burst and
accelerate through a hole i think you
add that to he can pass protect and he's
very good in the past game as a pass
catcher and all that to me i think
that's what makes him the best running
back in the draft and he's ready to go
and we'll start for somebody ready right
away next year
you had clyde edwards de lair at number
one last year josh jacobs number one the
year before how does atn compare
to the top guys from the last two years
yeah well like he's he's more along the
lines i think of a josh jacobs
than closer to the clyde edwards hilaire
type of player but
a little different than josh jacobs all
together i think he's got more to offer
in the past game as we talked about
maybe a little bit more of a space
running back compared to josh jacobs
who's awesome in between the tackles and
doing stuff like that hey clyde edwards
hilaire hey you and i saw it last year
right that first game was good after
that
was just eh it wasn't great it wasn't i
mean i think if we could do a do-over
jonathan taylor should have been the
number one running back in the draft i
don't think there's any doubt about that
you know so the thing i like about atn
compared to a clyde edward solaire mike
and this was the issue with edward
scalia there's just more pure speed you
know atn is a guy that's going to be
able to go 50 and 60 yards to the house
you know edwards hillary mike just to
hit on that real quick the one thing
about him
that
you know you you really he's a little
bit of the peter warwick syndrome
remember peter work from florida state
right and i say that because oh man
they're so quick and they can break your
ankles and make you look silly right and
do all that but there's a lack of
straightaway speed so it's like hey i
break the ankles of the first guy and
now hey i'm about to break the ankles of
the second guy and hey i'm taking off oh
wait the first guy caught me from behind
i didn't go anywhere like that that to
me was an issue uh atn's not going to
have that issue
i mean that's a great point you get past
that first guy you got to create
separation or someone's going to drag
you down they're going to come behind
that's right what's what's the point of
missing uh making the first guy miss if
you're gonna get dragged down a few
yards later you get a few extra yards
but you don't get the home run exactly
some of these guys are capable of
bringing not jay harris we heard from
him earlier he's not going to be happy
at being number four why isn't he higher
it it's he's a tough eval i'm not gonna
lie i mean it wasn't easy and i'm i'm
certainly he'll sit here and stay man
maybe what was tough about it well it's
first off he's he's not fast i mean it's
it's like i would i would i would say
it's probably high four six maybe four
seven type speed mike when we're talking
about the 40. so you know there's a lot
of holes he runs through and it's
alabama and they dominate people and you
go oh wow that looks good but you also
got to sit there and ask yourself and go
well damn everybody could run through
that hole and now okay now he's run
through that hole what's he gonna do he
does have tremendous quickness for his
size at 230 pounds he can break your
ankles and do that but you know there is
meat left on the bone uh because of his
inability to i look at plays and go that
should have been a 50 yard gain it was
25 yards and then even for as big as he
is mike
you know he doesn't run with great power
he'd rather make you miss than you know
try to run you over put his shoulder
down drive the pile that way that's not
what he is so you know i came away like
thinking he was more of like a let's say
a gus edwards that could catch the ball
you know gus edwards with the ravens i
think he's a real good player it's not a
knock you know gus edwards was some fred
jackson remember him from the bills back
in the day like receiving skills it's
like a little bit of a combination of
that but i think ultimately just not
explosive enough mike for me to make him
one of the top two or three running
backs in the draft
do any of the guys in this year's draft
in your estimation and this is always
difficult because you're comparing
apples
and oranges to the extreme with all the
different positions right do any of them
deserve to be first rounders last year
it was edwards a lair
just in that last spot in round one do
any of these guys in your mind deserve
to be among the first round picks no
they do not they they're this is this is
not a first round class i mean atn is
you know listen borderline certainly
you know but but again you know what
this list will show you here too is like
i mean some of the guys that we've seen
taken late in the draft in the first
round sony michelle rashad penny glide
edward solaire you know that hasn't
worked out all that well it hasn't you
know and then of course you got the the
the opposite of that where you look at
some of the top five picks in the draft
there with ezekiel elliott leonard
fournette saquon barkley
eh you know elliot's been pretty damn
good but uh
you know but but there's risk at this
position and no i think with the way
this draft plays out mike i don't think
there's any way
we see a running back uh go in the first
round no way
dollar for dollar spot for spot
i i just would not use a first round
pick on a running back unless i believed
i was getting jane brown james brown
well jim brown yeah right or or adrian
peterson
smith right an all-time great but even
then even then the one thing you don't
know in the one area where you're
rolling the dice is durability yeah you
don't know what the durability is going
to be at the next level and and and if
you've used a top 10 pick or even a top
32 pick on a running back
when you know that there are running
backs available at every round or all
the way down to james robinson we talked
earlier about how hard it was last year
for the undrafted guys to make a
difference he came in and won the
starting job at tailback in jacksonville
as an undrafted guy and had a great
season you can get these running backs
anywhere when you use that significant
draft capital you put yourself in a spot
where you got to use the guy maybe you
got to overuse the guy to justify it and
then he gets injured and then why in the
hell did you did you waste a first round
pick on a guy at a position where the
injury rate is going to be higher
because they're in as you say car
crashes all the time i just it's not
worth it get your running backs later
where was dalvin cook round two where
was derrick henry round two exactly
where was alan camaro round victory wait
wait wait exactly nick jobs i agreed
wait you know there there's no doubt
about that and mike you know the other
point i want to bring up is something
you said there yeah when i evaluate
running backs listen you got to change
your thought a little bit i'm not like
the days of like oh does he have
durability and is he going to last into
a second cut like no i'm sorry this
sounds insensitive but i evaluate these
running backs to go wait i got them for
three or four years and then we got to
look for a new one that's it i mean
that's that's how it goes and that's why
i favored guys like javion hawkins from
louisville who's 185 188 pounds and a
guy in michael carter who's at 200
pounds because they're home home run
hitters mike they're explosive as can be
and yeah i don't think their careers are
going to be long but i think they're
going to be really impactful in a short
period of time where it's going to be a
lot of big plays like the javion hawkins
kid from louisville he's raheem mostert
or breda right it's one of those guys
you know michael carter from unc i look
at him as like a devante freeman for the
falcons yeah their careers can be short
you know they can fall apart quickly but
they can make a lot of big plays in that
three or four year period to really help
your team
and you mentioned chubb and that gets
back to the point we made earlier this
week about the browns and they're so
heavy on analytics now this is the
ultimate test yeah forget what the guy's
done forget how many fans have bought
his jersey is it right to pay him eight
figures plus per year
or just roll the dice again and get a
mid-level guy and hope that he works out
and say hey we're we're playing the
numbers we're not playing the hits with
our our running back position
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports